عاد السائحون
عدد قليل منهم إلى
ساحة سان ماركو في البندقية ، ولا تزال العديد من الفنادق والمتاجر
مغلقة في المعبود الجندوليري ، حيث تستضيف المقاهي
طيور النورس أكثر من العملاء الذين
نجدها رائعة تقول ماري
كارولين كروزيت من فرنسا ،
لا توجد فترات انتظار في المتاحف
الكنائس كلها مفتوحة ،
يمكنك أن تأخذ وقتك
[موسيقى]
لكن اقتصاد البندقية الذي يعتمد بشكل كبير
على السياحة
لا يمكنه الانتظار حيث توافد حوالي 30 مليون زائر
إلى المدينة العام الماضي
قبل أن يتعاون فيروس كورونا مع
السياح وهذا هو الآن
هذا المتجر في  عائلة ماريو لأجيال
، لا يمكن أن يكون الأمر أسوأ من هذا ، كما يقول ،
لقد أعيد افتتاحنا في الثالث والعشرين من مايو ، ومنذ ذلك الحين
صنعنا حوالي
100 يورو من القلاع التي تزيد قليلاً عن
110 دولارات في شهر تقريبًا ،
اعتاد السكان على الحياة
دون حشود
الحشود المحتملة.  من العودة النهائية إلى ما
يشبه الحياة الطبيعية ،
تفتقد المرشدة السياحية المخضرمة كاتارينا سوبراداسي السائحين لكنها استمتعت
بالبطانة الفضية
.  حزينًا بطريقة معينة ، إنه
أمر رائع حقًا لأنه يمكننا
الاستمتاع
بمدينتنا ونأمل أن نعيد التشغيل شيئًا
فشيئًا خطوة بخطوة
، يجب على زوار المواقع
فحص درجات حرارةهم
وارتداء الأقنعة بالداخل والحفاظ على مسافة اجتماعية
مع ولادة جديدة  السياحة يأمل العديد من
السكان ألا يتم
تدمير المدينة في هذه العملية
في السياحة ، تحذر عالمة البيئة جين
ديموستو من أن البندقية
المهددة بالفعل بارتفاع المياه لا يمكن أن
تتحمل تدفقًا جديدًا من
السياح ، إنها ليست مجرد مسألة
تأثير
30 مليون شخص على  مجموعة جزر هشة للغاية
في وسط نظام بحيرة حساس ،
إنها أيضًا مسألة ما إذا كان كل هؤلاء
الأشخاص يسافرون عبر العالم في
جميع أنحاء البلاد
لقضاء مثل هذه الإجازات القصيرة ، حيث
تفكر حكومة البندقية
في فرض ضريبة على المدينة لمحاولة كبح
الطوفان  من قضاء
يوم التوفير ، تدير لورينزو لاين
فندقًا في قصر عمره 500 عام ،
يجب أن تكون محترمًا جدًا لأني أفكر
في كل شيء
يجب على الأشخاص الذين يأتون إلى البندقية ، وكذلك الأشخاص الذين يأتون إلى البندقية ، أن يتعلموا احترام المدينة ، وهي مدينة تتنقل بين الحاجة إلى كسب العيش والحفاظ على أسلوب حياة فريد. باستثناء المعجزة التي يعتقد أنها تعافى مؤخرًا فقط من فيروس كورونا بما في ذلك سبعة أيام على جهاز التنفس الصناعي في غيبوبة مستحثة طبيًا ، لم يكن الأمر مؤلمًا حقًا التنفس نفسه ولكن الجلد وأنا أعلم أنه لم يكن على الجلد نفسه كما كان في الرئتين البرتغاليتين على ما يبدو مهيأ للدمار من قبل covet 19 مع أقل عدد من أسرة العناية المركزة للفرد في الاتحاد الأوروبي بأكمله ، لكن حتى الآن كان العكس هو أن البرتغال كانت ناجحة جدًا في التعامل مع جائحة فيروس كورونا ، ويقولون إن الأمر أساسي. كانت نقاط استراتيجيتهم هي أنهم أغلقوا في وقت مبكر جدًا ثم قاموا أيضًا بإجراء اختبارات جماعية لمحاولة تخفيف الضغط على طبيبهم  النظام
أحد الأسباب المحتملة التي تجعل الأطباء في
أجنحة فيروس كورونا مثل هنا في
المستشفى الجامعي المركزي في لشبونة
يعالجون منذ أشهر المرضى الذين يعانون من
المنشطات لمكافحة الالتهاب في
الرئتين ، يخبرني رئيس وحدة العناية المركزة الدكتور نونو جيرمانو
أن
ما رأيناه مع العلاج القشري هو
أننا قادرون على تقليل
الالتهاب
وتحسين
وظيفة الجهاز التنفسي للمريض
بشكل كبير ، حيث يتم علاج 60 في المائة من المرضى الذين يخضعون للتهوية
هنا بالستيرويدات بما في ذلك
هذه المرأة البالغة من العمر 63 عامًا والتي كانت قادرة على
مغادرة وحدة العناية المركزة
بعد يوم واحد فقط من
تصوير أكسفورد جديد  وجدت الدراسة الآن أن هذا
النوع من العلاج يمكن أن يقلل من خطر
وفاة
المرضى في المستشفيات ، وتصفه منظمة الصحة العالمية
بأنه اختراق محتمل
يقول الدكتور جيرمانو إنه أداة
فعالة ساعدت في الحفاظ على عدد
الوفيات لمرضى العناية المركزة عند حوالي 16 في المائة
ولكن هذا ليس كل شيء  يفعلون ذلك ،
يحافظون عليها ،
لدينا فريق يقوم بالتواصل
خارج العناية المركزة
ويراقب المرضى و  ما نقوم به هو
إجراء التنبيب والتهوية
المبكرة للمريض حتى لا نؤخر التنبيب والتهوية للمريض أي مريض
لديه علامات صعوبة في التكاثر
والمعايير التي تحتاج إلى تهوية
ونقوم
بدخولهم مبكرًا إلى وحدة العناية المركزة
بينما البعض الآخر  يقول الخبراء في جميع أنحاء
العالم إنه يجب وضع المرضى فقط
على أجهزة التنفس الصناعي كملاذ
أخير ، يقول المتخصصون الطبيون هنا إن
التهوية المبكرة في ظروف معينة
كانت تعمل بالتأكيد ، وقد نجحت بالتأكيد
مع فرانسيسكو فونسيكا الذي يأمل أن يعود السائحون الآن بعد
أن عادت صحته
إلى البرتغال
أيضًا ومساعدته على بدء
نشاطه التجاري ،
فقد بدأت اليونان للتو السياحة
هذا الصيف من خلال فتح حدودها
تدريجيًا للترحيب بالزوار الدوليين بعد
إغلاق استمر قرابة ثلاثة أشهر ،
مما يعني أن المسافرين من العشرات من
البلدان ذات الخطورة المنخفضة
أصبحوا الآن  قادرون على دخول المطارين الرئيسيين في اليونان
الخاضعين فقط لفحوصات عشوائية لأولئك الذين
يصلون إلى اليونان من a li  يتعين أيضًا على
الدول ذات المخاطر العالية
الخضوع لفحوصات بعد
ما يسمى بفترة الجسر التي مدتها أسبوعين ،
ومن المتوقع أن تنمو قائمة البلدان
بحلول يوليو في الأول
، وهذا هو الوقت الذي ستنطلق فيه
الرحلات الجوية الدولية المباشرة إلى العديد من
الوجهات الصيفية في اليونان
أيضًا.  استئناف والحدود البرية والبحرية ،
كما تم الترحيب باليونان
كواحدة من أكثر الوجهات السياحية أمانًا
في العالم هذا الصيف
، وتشير المؤشرات من الصناعة حتى الآن
إلى أن هذا سيساعد في جذب
السياح لديها من بين أقل عدد من الوفيات
في أوروبا وهو  حوالي أقل من 119 حالة
حتى الآن
وما يزيد قليلاً عن 3000 حالة في عدد
سكان
يبلغ 11 مليونًا حيث تفتح البلاد
حدودها للسماح للأشخاص
في السؤال حول كيفية
إبعاد الفيروس
، فرضت اليونان بالفعل
إجراءات صارمة وحتى غرامات في البلاد
الحوادث التي لم يتم احترام التدابير فيها كما هو
الحال في الحانات والنوادي الليلية ،
كما أنها عززت بشكل كبير
نظامها الصحي في المناطق السياحية
الآن تأمل البلاد أن  سيُترجم النجاح المبكر
في الحرب ضد covet 19
إلى عائدات السياحة التي تشتد الحاجة
إليها نظرًا لاعتمادها الهائل على السياحة
التي تمثل أكثر من 20 في المائة من
اقتصادها ، وستتأثر البلاد اقتصاديًا ولكن
بدرجة أقل إذا اختار أولئك الذين يسافرون هذا
الصيف
لقضاء عطلة في اليونان في
لينديلوف سي إن
باركر على الساحل الأيوني لليونان